مساء الخير سؤال يستحق البحث عن اجابه
عليه الوسائل العرب يبقوا في السلطه حتى
اخر يوم من اعمارهم رغم انهم يحكمون
الجمهوريه
والحكومه رغم الشيخوخه ورغم المرض والاغرب
انه يعملوا دكتور شريحه كبيره من شعوبهم
التي لا تمانع ولا لحظات انتقال السلطه
لتكون لحظات تعثر وتوتر والتحول وربما
اضطرابات حتى داخل الملكيات اللي شاهد
الصوره من المحيطه الخليجيه لاحظ امر ملفت
للنظر هذا الامر انه طول اعمار الحكام
العرب بشكل كبير جدا مقارنه ب المواطنين
او متوسط عمر الشعوب
يعني متوسط اعمار المواطنين
متوسط اعمار الحكام العرب في اللحظه اللي
انا بكلم حضراتكم فيها اثنين وسبعين ساعه
فيما توصل اعمار المواطنين العرب من
المحيط الى الخليج خمسه وعشرين سنه يعني
فرق بنتكلم على اكثر من خمسه واربعين سنه
تقريبا على شان فهم ظاهره دي تعالوا ناخذ
صوره كنا بانوراما على
الانظمه العربيه من المحيط للخليج احنا في
العالم العربي عندنا
جمهوريات الملكيات سته دول الخليج السبت
الملكيه التمنيات دول الخليج السته
وبالاضافه الاردن الغربيه فيما يتعلق بدول
الخليج ديب وتصنف على انها ملكيات
استبداديه او ملكيه مطلقه حيث يملك الملك
ويحكم وفي هذه تتكدس كل السلطات الكبيره
والصغيره بالنسبه للاردن والمغرب على
الورق هي ملكيات الدستوريه الملك يملك ولا
يحكم
سلطات مؤسسات الدوله المختلفه ده نظريا
لكن عمليا الملك عبد الله والملك محمد
عندهم سلطات اكبر بكثير طبعا من اي بلد
اخر في العالم اذا كنا نتكلم على الملكيات
الدستوريه الحقيقيه بريطانيا الدول
العربيه هي جمهوريات في الجمهوريات
الاختلاف الاساسي بينها وبين الملكيات هو
فكره تداول السلطه يعني
رئيس مدى الحياه لكن واقع الامر الماليه
نشوف فتره ولايه الرئيس في باقي في
الجمهوريات العربيه ممكن نصنفها الى اربعه
التصنيف الاولاني الدول اللي بتحدد ولايه
الرئيس في فتره واحده وب تلتزم بهذا وهذا
التصنيف تقع في بس لبنان الدوله الوحيده
اللي هي بتقول ان رئيس الجمهوريه يبقى في
السلطه الى ست سنوات ولا يستطيع او لا
يمكن له التجديد او البقاء في السلطه
والعوده للسلطه مره اخرى الا بعد خروجه من
السلطه لمده ست سرعه وفي شريحه اخرى بتعمل
اه يعني اه مفتوحه وبالتالي الجزائر مثلا
يجوز للرئيس عبد العزيز بوتفليقه ان يبقى
في السلطه الى ما شاء الله ان امضى الله
في عمره وفي دول اخرى بتحدد
الولايه ب فترتين او اكثر لكن الاحزاب
الحاكمه او الرؤساء بيسهل تغيير هذا الوضع
ما بيلتزم وجبه ناخذ مثال مثلا الاكثر
الحاحا الان هو المثال السوداني الرئيس
عمر البشير يحكم من عام تسعه وثمانين تحت
المسميات المختلفه مجلس عسكري
ثم انتخابات رئاسيه
فتره انتقاليه من 2005 2010 ثم انتخابات
رئاسيه ثم يعني اجمالي عدد السنوات التي
قضاها تكتمل الاتي في العام المقبل والان
في استعدادات او تمهيد للمسرح السياسيه في
السودان الى ولايه تابعه للرئيس عمر
الاشياء الرئيس الموريتاني اراد ايضا بعد
قضاء فترتين وفقا للدستور الموريتاني انه
يسعى الى فتره ثالثه
وهناك في التصنيف الرابع في الدول العربيه
اللي هو ال الرئيس اللي بيبقى بحكم الامر
بحكم الامر الواقع بسبب ظروف الاضطرابات
فتجد مثلا انه ابرز مثال الرئيس الفلسطيني
محمود عباس ابو مازن
اللي انتهت فتره ولايه رسميا سنه الفين
وتسعه ولمده تسع سنين عليه الرجل باقي في
السلطه بنود انتخابات ولا اريد انتخابات
ولكن حكم الظروف الخلافات ما بين حماس
وفتح
وبحكم الاعتداءات الاسرائيليه المتكرره
على الاراضي الفلسطينيه لاشكال الولايه او
اشكال الجمهوريات المالي انشوف كده ال ال
التفسير ربما العلماء العلماء استاذه
العلوم السياسيه والاجتماع يعني قضوا
عمرهم في دراسه هذه الظاهره لكن ابسط
تفسير الظاهره قدر تلخص وفي الملحوظه اللي
قرارها الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
اكثر من مره قبل ان يتوقف عنها ربما يعني
بنصيحه احد مستشارين لما كان بيوصف الدوله
المصريه وهي اقدم دوله في التاريخ بانها
دوله بينها شبه دوله وليس الدوله هناك
لمصادقه جدا بالمناسبه يعني المقصود بشبه
الدوله ولا ينطبق على مسبق على باقي الدول
العربيه في دوله بمعنى ان مؤسسات الدوله
الحديثه في مصر في باقي دول العظيم مؤسسات
ضعيفه جدا هي مؤسسه الدوله الحديثه
البرلمان الاحزاب ومؤسسات المجتمع المدني
النقابات
الصحافه الارض هكذا هذه المؤسسات حين تكون
عافيه بتقوم بدور اللي شخصا
تقوم بدور الحق بتعمل دور حيوي في المجتمع
بدو بدو الرقابه على السلطه القائمه
يبقى في حزب حاكم وحزب المعارض في رقابه
عليه في مؤسسات بدو رساله وبالتالي في
انتقال سلس للسلطه حتى لا يستطيع الرئيس
ان يبقى في وجود هذه المؤسسات الى مدى
الحياه لان في مجتمع حيوي يخرج اخرين
ملزمه بتطبيق الدستور اللي لا يمكن يسمح
في جمهوريه بالبقاء مثل الحياه في عشان
تعرف
المؤسسات دورها مهم اعطيكم مثالين في
دولتين عربيتين دوله غير عربيه الدولتين
العربيتين واحده منهم في الجزائر الرئيس
الدستور الجزائري مشكور عمره يسمح
بفترات او مفتوحه ولكن الرجل جائر السلطه
سنه تسعه وتسعين ومع نهايه الفتره الولايه
الثانيه سنه الفين وثمانيه راى يعني
النافذين في الدوله انه الافضل ان يبقى
الرئيس بوتفليقه بتغيير الدستور وجعلها
مورد مفتوحه ولم يجدوا مقاومه من المؤسسات
الدوله اللي كانت ضعيفه وهشه ما تقدرش
اهداف استقرار الجزائر وبعد العشريه
السوداء فهو كان رئيس بالضروره من ناحيه
وفي نفس الوقت مؤسسات الدوله المدنيه
ضعيفه في مقابل القوه
للمؤسسات العسكريه والامنيه في المقابل
تونس اللي فيها اكثر دول العالم العربي
يعني تعافيه
اساسات وقدرتها على انها تبقى دوله اقرب
للحداثه لما اراه حزب حركه النهضه لما
ارادت انها تستاثر بالسلطه بشكل اكبر في
السنوات الاخيره اللي تصدى لها كان مؤسسات
الدوله المتمثله في اتحاد الشغل اللي هو
يعني اتحاد العمال في دول اخرى وبعد
النقابات مثلا نقابه نقابه المحامين لولا
هذه المؤسسات كان حزب الله استغفر نصيب من
قبل السلطه ويعني تغيرت الصوره في السودان
في تونس اذا كان هذا هو التفسير طبعا طبعا
ممكن ناخذ مثال تاني في اه الدول العربيه
وليكن مثلا الولايات المتحده اكثر ال او
اكبر الدول العالم الديمقراطيه الان
لان الولايات المتحده
وقد لا تصدقه هذا ما كانش فيه نص في
الدستور الامريكي بيمنع انه الرئيس يبقى
الاكثر من متين ولكن كانت التوازنات او
تكافئ القوى ما بين الحزب الديمقراطي
والحزب الجمهوري هو اللي بيقبل الرئيس على
ارض الواقع من دون نص دستوري انه لا يبقى
اكثر من فترتين لما حدث استثنائي وهي
الحرب العالميه الثانيه وبقي الرئيس
الاكثر بالموجودين الى ثلاث مدن وتنبه
المجتمع الامريكي الى خطوره هذا الاستثناء
النصفي الدستور الامريكي على ان لا يجوز
ان يبقى الرئيس الامريكي اكثر من فترتين
واصبحت الان نص الدستور يعني يعني المشكله
مش في النص الدستوري ولكن في قوه المؤسسات
وليس في نصوص الدساتير من الدستور في
السودان لا فترتين لكن
يتم تغييره تم التمهيد دلوقتي ربما البعض
كمان يسعى الى تغيير مماثله في الدول
الاخرى زي مصر اي دوله اخرى يعني في مقابل
ضعف لمؤسسات الدوله الحديثه هناك قوه
كبيره بيقول عليها ال الباحثين يعني
مؤسسات المجتمع التقليدي اللي هي ببساطه
او يعني اختصارا القبيله والدين هذه
المؤسسات قيم القبيله وقيم الدين اكثر
تاثيرا في المواطن العربي من الدوله
الحديثه او مؤسسات الدوله الحديثه تقوم
تتخيلوا ما اقصد هم لو اخذنا بسبب العراق
الاكثر تاثيرا في العراق في جموع الناس
هناك رئيس الحكومه او رئيس البرلمان ولا
ايه الله السيستاني
ايه الله السيستاني اللي كلمته نافذه
ويعني يطيعها عشرات الملايين من اتباعه في
كل مكان اكثر بكثير من رئيس الحكومه او
رئيس البرلمان
الاكثر تاثيرا في وقت الازمات رؤساء
العشائر ورؤساء الاحزاب يعني لما كان فيه
مظاهرات في البصره وارادت الحكومه اللي هي
تتفاوض او تتحدث مع احد رؤساء الاحزاب
اللي تحدث عن رؤساء العشائر اوضح لكم
بدايه بنيه المجتمع بتاثر البنيه المؤثره
مش المؤسسات الحديث هذه يعني في بريطانيا
مثلا حد الى حد ان تبني عشيه ولن ت دينك
ايه ولا انت جاي من اي بلد او علت كلا هو
بيبقى ينتمي الى اه نقابه بينتمي الى
اتحاد ينتمي الى حزب وبالتالي دي مؤسسات
الدوله الحديثه اللي بتحل محل العائله
والعشيره وكذلك الدين
لتحقيق المذهب والطائفه مؤثر جدا زي ما
قلت الحضارات قوه في عشرات الامثله يعني
يعني يعني لديكم امثله ويفكروا فيها في
العالم العربي الناس لا تمانع في دفع
الزكاه والعشور اذا كانوا مسيحيين لكن في
مقاومه شديده لفكره الطريقه الضريبه
مرتبطه ب احد اساسيات الدوله الحديث لازم
كل مواطن يدفع الضريبه وهي وعدم دفع لها
الدهم المخلص الشخص لما لا تقوم دوله حديث
انما الزكاه قيمه دينيه انا بستغرب
وامثله كثيره جدا منها مثلا اجماع الناس
على مخالفه القانون عيانا بيانا القوانين
في كثير من الدول العربيه بتمنع الزرق عند
سن معين القصه لكن المجتمعات ثقافه
القبيله لا تمانع ثقافه الدين لا تمانع
وبالتالي بيضربوا عرض الحائط وقوانين
الدوله
لا هو المشهد قوه المؤسسات
القبيله الدين في مقابل ضعفه مؤسسات
الدوله الحديثه وقوه المؤسسات القبيله
والدين قيم القبيله وقيم الدين لا تعارض
بال ربما تبارك بقاء الرئيس الى ما شاء
الله من قبيل تبقى الكبير او من قبيل عدم
الخروج على ولي الامر الى اخره هو ده ال
ال السبب الرئيس هو
السبب الرئيس هو طبعا بالاضافه لاسباب
الاضطرابات المستمره ذا يضع
مؤسسات الدوله معناها انه ما فيش يعني
استياء كبير قوي او ترسخ الفكره الفكره
فكره تداول والسلطه فكره استغلال الرؤساء
في ضعفه مؤسسات لكن لما الرئيس بري كما
يفعل اضعاف اكثر حتى يبقى في السلطه اكثر
اكثر اذا كان هذا هو الخلل فما هو العلاج
لانه صعب جدا العلاج معناها انه احنا في
مرحله واحنا كان مجتمعات في مرحله معينه
في مرحله معينه من مراحل التطور الدوله
الحديث احنا فينا عند مرحله مبكره جدا
مرحله الطفوله
ونحتاج الى سنوات طويله من النطق
قياسا على ما حدث في مجتمعات اخرى انه
بالتعليم الجيد جدا اللي بيقرر الناس يكون
عندهم وعي كبير يكون عندهم قدره على
الاستقلال الاقتصادي
نوع النشاط الاقتصادي اللي يؤدي الى طبقه
وصفه كبيره الطبقه الوسطى الكبيره دى
بتبقى قادره مستعده الى تكوين احزاب
شرطه في مؤسسات مجتمع مدني مختلفه لما
بتكون في صناعه مجتمع صناعي صناعه ضروريه
جدا للتطور الديمقراطيه يكون فيه نقابات
ويكون في مؤسسات مختلفه لتمثيل الناس اللي
موجودين في المجتمع وال شخص واحد وبالتالي
بيتري بعدين حركه
ومؤسسات قويه ومسانده ضرائب ومادامت دفع
الضرائب ان تحاسب المسؤولين عمليه تطور
وعمليات التطور ديه مكلفه
مكلفه للمجتمعات على كل الصغر وفيها
تعثرات وفيها ثورات وفيها دماء وفيها رحله
كفاح كبيره الى ان يحدث هذا سوف نظل في
العالم العربي يعني معاني من ظاهره الحاكم
الذي يبقى حتى اخر يوم في الحياه اشكركم
وقبل ان اترككم في امان الله احب او
لحضرتكم انه انا مدرك اللي فيه ضخمه جدا
تاتي من الاسئله
لانه انا بعد الاجابه على الاسئله ولكن
اخر لكن والله هذا لاسباب ضروريه جدا منها
انه احنا بنحاول ان صيغه اكبر عدد من
الاسئله بس في نفس الوقت تكون اجابات يعني
اه يعني اجابات
جيده الخضره كثير المعظم الحلقات اللي انا
بعملها كتب مبنيه على اسئلتكم
لكن انا اوعدكم انه في الاسابيع القادمه
انشاء الله في حلقات متواليه الاجابه على
الات حضرتكم اترككم في امان الان
ام